That profile pic, awesome.
When you're a dad, hugs can be bear hugs,...
...but they can also be high fives, fist bumps and next-level handshakes.
Kids, they're our best friends.
They're our greatest fans.
Buddy, you've been getting muscle mass. Nice!
And they look to us like the same way we look at superheroes: up...
...because we're taller.
Now, dadhood isn't always easy.
When a rule is broken, we're the enforcement.
Hey buddy, it's garbage day.
But when a heart is broken, we're the reinforcement.
And we wouldn't have it any other way because being a dad is awesome.
Just like new Peanut Butter Cheerios are awesome.
That's why it's the official cereal of dadhood.
And this, this my friends,...
...this is how to dad.